hi everyone and thank you for the
opportunity to speak to you today about
our experience with large-scale clinical
lab
testing with the tacpathcova 19 assay
i'm very pleased to tell you what our
experience has been um so let me go
ahead and get started first i want to
kind of explain to you what clinical
pathology laboratories is we're part of
sonic healthcare worldwide
which is an australian-based parent
company with operations
in western europe australia new zealand
and the united states
sonic has been obviously a global
response partner to the pandemic as it
has swept across the world
and each of our countries has responded
as their populations
needed the test services that we offer
within the united states sonic
healthcare us
is a federation of laboratories each
serving defined geographies
we have about nine regional laboratories
with various test sites across
slightly over half the country the sites
that you see in blue are large reference
laboratories that serve
large populations in high throughput lab
settings
the map pins that you see in orange
would be regional stat laboratories or
anatomic pathology laboratories
clinical pathology laboratories has been
in operation for more than 70 years they
were one of the first laboratories in
central texas
uh they brought a near real-time or next
day service in
anatomic pathology very early on they
were the first to bring the
pap testing services to central texas
in the 40s and 50s and at this point
that we've grown with the
area and we're an intimate part of the
community
we now expand to eight states texas and
surrounding states
and we serve virtually every laboratory
need
that people would have so we have
departments of microbiology chemistry
cytology histology
microbiology and molecular testing
we have a very mature operational force
so we have courier networks that span
our geographies
so we can very efficiently bring samples
into the laboratory for testing
we also have mature customer service
operations that are local to the
geographies that they serve
and we have a centralized exception
handling department so that as
exceptions come up
which they always do we can respond to
them quickly to provide the best we can
in patient care
so the outline of my talk will be to
tell you a little bit about how we've
implemented the tacpath testing here at
clinical pathology laboratories
i want to paint a picture of what the
workflow looks like because the attack
path assay looks
fairly different from what a high volume
reference lab or hospital lab would
normally see
i'll talk to you a little bit about the
quality control and pathologies of this
assay
and what some of its operational
characteristics are now that we've been
in operation for several months
um and then you know we're all
interested in how the pandemic is
unfolding
so i'll show you some comparison to
antibody results
which i think are just interesting and
you know self-validating
uh in the overall testing paradigms that
we serve
all right so moving into how we've
responded at clinical pathology
laboratories
we like i think every laboratory in the
country have been very active
since uh the march time frame to bring
on testing
our first test that we launched here was
march 11th with the roche kobas
assay we launched igg serology testing
in april
we did a lot of work with the tacpath
assay
before the 384 wall version was
fda cleared under the eua approval
process we had
developed a laboratory developed test at
384 because we recognized that demand
was going to
far outstrip capacity unless we moved to
a 3d four-wheel platform
so we launched in april with that in our
own eua submission
and then we're very pleased with the
progress that thermo fisher made
at expanding their eua and were able to
go back to their ifu
based methods in as those launched
then that expansion continued in may uh
where we launched a total antibody assay
for stars kobe 2
and then in june we've also launched on
the hologic panther platform so we offer
at this point three different platforms
for nucleic acid testing uh for stars
cov2 the roche platform the whole logic
platform and the thermo fischer
cova 19 assay
all right so the basics of this assay uh
as you may already be aware of specimen
collection follows routine
collections that you would have for
upper respiratory specimens
the instructions for use are fairly
broad nasopharyngeal or
pharyngeal nasal and mid-turbinate swabs
as well as nasopharyngeal aspirates
uh and bronchiol alveolar lavages we
don't see very many of those anymore
most of the uh screening now is most of
the testing now is
is nasal-based as that's the
recommendation from cdc um
so specimen collection handled primarily
by our clients
uh although cpl operates a variety of
patient service centers uh
in the territories that we serve we do
not collect respiratory specimens
because that requires specialized
training
and expertise and ppe and environment
that is not normal for a blood typical
blood collection
so specimens arrive here at the
laboratory under controlled conditions
appropriate to the stability of the
specimens
and then the first step of the
extraction process
is using the kingfisher
platform and the magmax viral slash
pathogen nucleic acid
kit we have migrated onto the version
two of that kit
and we're using kingfishers for all of
that uh extraction
and then in the analytical assay itself
the q
rt pcr is simultaneously detecting three
different targets
uh plus one exogenous control and ms2
phage control
uh that is spiked in prior to extraction
to verify the extraction on each sample
so those are the basics of the assay
as we map the assay onto a typical
clinical workflow
uh many of you in the clinical space are
familiar with
uh you know the stages of clinical
testing pre-analytical analytical and
post-analytical um
i'm kind of leaving off
pre-pre-analytical and post-post
analytical out of this
discussion um great many steps in each
one of these
and and the reason i wanted to put this
up here is
first of all to say you know the the
excuse me the thermo fisher assay is
really the yellow box in the middle
right the sample prep extraction correct
bcr setup
analysis curve review and release
but the steps that elaborate cpl really
focuses on a lot
have to do with pre-analytical because
you can find many published studies that
say that the majority of errors or
mistakes that happen
in clinical testing are often
pre-analytical a specimen being
incorrectly labeled
with respect to who the patient was or
incorrect incorrectly collected
so um we do a lot of work in all of our
systems and processes to
both give clients feedback when we spot
errors get those errors resolved
and then continuously educate them so
these different steps are of course
independent
in the pre-analytical step from the
testing platform
so on the left-hand side of the screen
here you see the detailed steps
to the thermo fisher tech path assay and
on the right hand side you see
what would be a typical workflow for the
roescher hologic platforms
the roscher hallogic platforms are
large-scale automated platforms designed
for clinical testing you know from the
ground up
they've had fda clearance for tests like
viral load for years now
um and so while they're analytically
much more straightforward a technician
is just loading sample
and reagents on the instrument and then
coming back later for a qc
review and review of the interpretation
and release
all of the precursor steps the
pre-analytical steps are are basically
the same
and the post analytical steps are
basically the same
we have to provide support to our
physician clients
uh for result interpretation right if
there's a
uh so for example if a patient's
particular
uh course you know they present with uh
the types of manifestations of a coveted
infection and then they get a
presumptive positive result back
for example or in the thermo fisher
workflow
you have an inconclusive and then you're
according to package insert
going to retest that inconclusive again
uh and give a report out and it may
be genuinely inconclusive so we need to
be able to help
clinicians understand and interpret that
in the context of a patient's
you know disease progression um
and that's true across all the platforms
the other point i wanted to make on this
graph though is that uh
you see the the there are a great number
of steps in the thermo fissure
path more than on the roche or whole
logic side
and to be frank i think that's one of
the powers of the the
thermo fisher assay and one of the
reasons they were able to scale up
is that you know each one of those steps
could be managed independently where the
the large monolithic platforms
uh if you just have a single step or a
single reagent or a single pipette tip
uh that is a limiting reagent uh you are
unable to expand those platforms and in
fact that's
that's been a struggle uh you know
across the molecular space
as the pandemic has uh unfolded globally
but thermal fissure in our experience
has done a very good job of
not having supply constraints or being
able to
you know source alternate materials like
they did moving from the
mvp1 to the mvp2 kits for the extraction
process
but that puts a little bit more
complexity back on us to manage each one
of these separate process steps
as we operationalize the assay obviously
we're looking for as much automation
and control as possible to ensure a
quality result with every specimen
part of that is done by training so we
spend a lot of time
uh training each technician as we've had
to scale up this
uh not only are we scaling up the
materials we're scaling up the labor
force
uh required and so we spent a lot of
time on training
we spent a lot of time on understanding
where are key control points in the
assay
that will give us an indication as to
the quality of the assay or the quality
of the results so that if something goes
wrong
we can catch it intervene before the
result is released out to the physician
or the patient
for action um the other thing i'll point
out
that especially early on uh was a
critical bottleneck
operationally for both of these assays
both the the automated platforms and the
attack path platform
is the step labeled aliquot um
where we're moving the specimen out of
the primary collection device
into the device that the testing process
requires in the case of tack path of
course that's a 96 well plate
in the case of the roche or hole logic
platforms that's a dedicated specimen
analysis tube that's designed for the
the automation platform
the only other difference between the
two is the batch building process
obviously tack path
being oriented around microwell plates
requires you to group specimens into
some type of batch
that's not unprecedented in the clinical
laboratory but is
obviously a critical step when we're
trying to track specimens
uh it's not infrequent that um a batch
of specimens may come in
and then the the patient's condition
changes say they're a hospitalized
patient
and we need to be able to quickly
identify which batches that
patients specimen in and estimate for
the client when we'll have a result out
to them so that they can make clinical
uh decisions so we built some custom
workflow elements to track that
batching process so that we could
respond quickly to client requests
um and be able to track specimens well
um all right that's i think the crux of
the
comparison the clinical workflows
now i want to um give you a little bit
more detail about some of these steps in
the analytical workflow
comparison um on the roche 6800 or 8800
platforms or the halogen panther
it's really fairly straightforward the
aliquoting steps are about the same
as between the the tack path method
um the tack path method takes a little
bit more care
obviously because instead of going from
a single tube to a single tube
that you're doing on the 6800 of the
holograph platform you're moving from a
single tube into a well of a 96 well
plate
and so again we spend a great deal of
time on staff training and
and methods to ensure that the accuracy
of that transfer is high
um the automated platforms
uh you know come pre-kitted uh with
fairly large batch sizes 250 or 192
and both instruments are basically
continuous load
so we can have our specimens ready
aliquoted and just continuously load the
machine with both reagents
and specimens and then the results
automatically merge into our las
on the tacpath side it's a little bit
more batch oriented again because it's
tied to a 96 well plate
so we perform the aliquoting um
into 96 well plates we do uh what i
would call a sample pre-preparation
uh to combine the specimen with uh
ace k a bead binding buffer and the ms2
internal control
um that's done on a biomac fx or a
biomac i5 in our case
uh and the output of that process is a
single 96 well plate that's ready to go
on to the thermo fisher kingfisher
instruments for extraction uh the
kingfisher instruments are very
straightforward they're loaded with
the the specimens that are pre-prepared
as i just described
along with two wash buffers and an
illusion
and the tip comb that's required for
that magnetic bead extraction
those go on to the machine they're very
reliable in our experience
23 minutes later you have extracted rna
we then take batches of four of those 96
well plates
and plate them into one 384 well plate
we use either manual or automated 96
wall pipettors
there is one step that's a little bit
inconvenient to be able to add a manual
kit control at that stage there is one
control
that's required per the instructions for
use
as a positive control that is post
extraction
so that's added at that point if you
were to tally up the
times here um well
i should continue on so you run the qpcr
70 minutes
but only five minutes of that is
hands-on time uh and then there's maybe
another five minutes after the run
uh to qc the results check the curves
transfer the analysis file uh use the
covert interpretive software provided by
thermofisher to
generate the clinical interpretations uh
and upload those and release those into
the lis
so it's a straightforward linear
workflow not a tremendous amount of
hands-on time
more so than the automated platforms but
at the same time if you were to look at
throughput uh or even throughput per ftp
fte it's uh quite a high throughput
platform we're able to produce a
large number of results um and again
unlike
the uh the automated platforms you know
the ability to add
incremental capacity uh is much more
straightforward especially once you have
a trained workforce
and your procedures and process and
environment are set up appropriate to
the testing
all right so if we were to look now
again at throughput
uh and these are just sort of nominal
examples
uh in our experience so they may or may
not match
exactly what the vendor specifications
are
uh for the devices but this is sort of
our practical experience
single roche 8800 can produce about 3
500 results per day
with one fte per shift so
we've been operating three shifts uh
seven days a week
pretty much since the pandemic started
so multiply you know that 3 500 is
divided across three shifts
per day um a single hologic panther can
produce about 750 results a day with one
fte per shift
and that single fte on the panther or
the 800
actually probably has enough time to be
able to staff
additional instruments in those cases um
if you compare that to sort of what i
would call the the minimal
implementation of the
fisher tacpath assay
that would be with two uh thermo fisher
3d four well
quant studio sevens uh with three
of the 96 well kingfishers that's sort
of in our experience a rate match
between those two instruments uh
assuming
zero downtime for all those instruments
uh
that system can produce about 12 000
results a day
but requires about nine ftes per shift
so much higher demand on labor but
obviously much higher
throughput as well
all right quality control so as i
mentioned
you know taking taking any uh
fda approved test and implementing the
laboratory
the laboratory is always keenly
concerned with what are the quality
control points of this assay
in our environment so that we can assure
a quality result for every patient
the instructions for use from the
manufacturer are quoted there and i
apologize they're in fairly
fine print but it as many
package inserts do is a little vague it
says a minimum of one negative control
and one positive control must be present
for each run
additional negative control wells must
be run for each extraction that is
represented on
a real-time pcr plate uh and then of
course all the control wells must pass
and the covet interpreted software will
actually invalidate either individual
results or the entire run
based on the results of those of those
qc
but we had a few concerns about that
because as you would imagine
um in a batch process like this we're
taking 496 wall plates
that have each been separately extracted
combining them into one 3d four wall
plate
and then every single well of course has
the ms2
exogenous control added to it
so if you follow that through strictly
uh there is no true no template control
every task ntc
that we designate is expected to have
ms2 in it
the manufacturer provided positive
control
that's a post extraction control does
not have ms2 in it
but there's no well on the plate that
has nothing in it where you would expect
no amplification
and obviously if you know in a worst
case scenario if ms2
the exogenous control were to somehow
contaminate master mix
basically there's no uh explicit control
for that
so we went ahead and defined locations
where there is a true
no possi you know no template of any
sort including ms2
is added and we verify that there is no
amplification
in that well as well
the second thing is that the
instructions for use and the
is in this case stands for the
interpretive software
um they both rely solely on the positive
control which is a post-extraction
control
uh and it must not contain ms2
we like the idea of having a positive
control
throughout the process that we can
detect for example
uh if there could be any issues in
reduced sensitivity related to
uh you know extraction uh issues if
an instrument's uh temperature control
were to be varying or any other minor
process problem rather related to
equipment or reagents or personnel
so we went ahead and added positive
controls to every 96 well plate in
addition to the recommended
negative controls in each 96 wall plate
the other thing we note about the assay
is that while we overall
uh you know are pleased with the
stringency of the interpretive
software's
evaluation of qc it offers no direct
support for
individual 96 well plate quality control
it tends to either fail or pass the
entire 3d four well plate
for example if any uh no template
control
in the 96 hole plate is non-negative it
fails the entire 384 well plate
and the interpretive software offers no
explicit support for a positive
extraction control
so we've gone ahead and added those
elements so that our technicians can
more readily
evaluate both on an individual batch
basis
the quality of the positives or the
negatives
on an individual 96 well plate this also
enables us to do longitudinal tracking
of positive controls
which the interpretive software does not
support um
large clinical labs are very accustomed
to looking at uh
lj charts you know for example in a in a
chemistry department
where you're looking for stability of
the assay over time
uh so that you could detect shifts or
trends
uh biases that may be coming into the
assay
again in a molecular context uh
typically
especially in molecular context where
the test is a qualitative test
um it's usually easy to spot when things
are are very bad right your positive
controls go negative or your negative
controls go positive
uh but having longitudinal ability to
look at positive controls
uh we think gives us an additional level
of comfort
uh of stability again of process people
equipment
across the across time
all right um i've pretty well described
everything that is on this we do monitor
each 3d four wall plate for a true no
template control
um we not only add one we actually add
two positive controls and i'll explain
why in a few slides
that enables us to look for possible
rotation of the 96 well plate
in the thermo fissure processes and in
many 96 well plate oriented processes
uh one can rotate the plate uh because
the plates are not
keyed generally to their orientation uh
and it can be a very difficult to detect
failure or problem
so by adding uh two distinct positive
controls each with
slightly different expected ct values it
gives us an enhanced ability to detect
for uh
an inadvertent rotation of a 96-hole
plate in the process
we do assess extraction controls
throughout the process
and we watch batch positivity rate
we have found across all platforms the
roche platform the holographic platform
and the tacpat platform
over time uh that watching positivity
rate
uh is probably one of the best measures
of individual batch quality
and lets you very quickly uh assess if
something's gone wrong in
in a batch all right
we did built effectively a lightweight
middleware uh
using uh the r programming language to
support these qc functions and some
web-based tools that enable our
technicians to interact with and
understand
what the qc is of every batch as they
move along
all right all right now moving on to
pathologies uh this is an example of a
screenshot of one of those qc tools that
i mentioned
it basically is a is a simple heat map
that just shows positive negative
invalid uh across the entire 384 well
plate
in our case our 96 well plates are
interleaved so for example the 384 well
quadrant a1
is our alpha plate our first of the four
plates
uh a2 would be the second uh
b b one is the third and b two is the
fourth
um so when you see a pattern like this
in this case yellow
represents positive results uh red or
invalid and gray or negative
and you see these striking bands at the
edges of the plate
uh that there's just a lot of positives
and this is an unusually high positivity
rate so that would
that would be flagged immediately um and
in fact when
when we went back you know the the
technician caught this at the time
uh we went back and looked at the plate
and indeed the the
adhesive seal that's applied to the 384
well plate manually before it goes into
the
real-time pcr machine had not been
sealed well at the edges
and there's a very aggressive vortexing
step that's required in this assay
uh immediately prior to rtpcr to ensure
that the rna template and the master mix
are well mixed
and so by not having those seals at the
edges of the plate
there was just enough positivity to
bridge across
you know if you have an adhesive feel
seal that's not fully sealed
it becomes a wicking bridge to transport
sample
and so we believe that's what happened
in this case so easily caught
easily understood easily fixed
operationally
and not released so this was rerun
before being released
all right another uh few pathologies
that are easy to spot
at this level um you can see the the
right hand
graph uh now i've shifted the uh
the key in this case now purple is
positive
yellow is negative and gray are invalid
and you see this clear checkerboard
pattern in the right hand panel
of gray wells and that was an indication
that
in fact in a manual step a technician
just simply did not add
ms2 to a 96 wall plate
operationally inconvenient but no risk
to
quality of results because it's easily
spotted and flagged
again in our middle where we would flag
this level of ms2 missing
the panel on the on the right actually
shows
just a small run of those
gray wells indicating that possibly
a row of pipette tips at that row on one
particular plate did not have good seal
um or maybe there was a bow in the plate
or the
the source plate for ms2
was you know under volume it's difficult
to know exactly what the root cause of
that was
but it's almost certainly something
related to pipetting
so these plate level views are
invaluable to spot
pathologies in the process
the other thing as i mentioned we look
at are positive extraction controls over
time
and i mentioned we used two different
extraction controls positive control 2
showing box plots of of both 1 and 2
in this graph over time positive control
2 in the lower panel
is a 1-4 dilution of positive control 1.
so you would expect
a 2-ct shift upward in those controls
you will see step functions so somewhere
around i don't know july
25th or so we changed controls
control lots meaning we made a new batch
of the extraction controls
we actually make these extraction
controls from previously tested
high patient positives that are diluted
down so that they
are higher in ct values so they're a
fairly sensitive positive control
to any issues that may be impacting
sensitivity of the assay and then again
somewhere around i would say august 20th
or so you see a shift up in the cts as
we changed lots again
so um you know it's easy to obviously we
document the the changes of the lots
uh it's easy for the supervisory staff
to look at these
and ensure that uh you know the assay
itself is not
shifting performance over time i've
bracketed ct values of 25 and 30 just
arbitrarily so you can get
a better sense of where the medians and
the
interquartile ranges are for the pc
values
the other thing i'd point out which is
something we're generally pleased with
is how tight the data is
so the method tends to be very
reproducible um
and within a lot uh we tend to see
very good uh stability over time
um some of the data points off to the
uh right hand side of the graph where
you see a little bit more variability
um interestingly and i'll get to this in
a few graphs our volume has gone down so
there's a little bit more variability
just associated with reduced volume over
time
and that's just a factor that you just
have to keep in mind
all right the next thing i wanted to go
over was i had mentioned this
the fact that we use these extraction
controls also to
to detect possible plate rotations
um as an example uh every 3d four well
plate which is the panel you see on the
bottom
is comprised of four 96 well plates and
you see what we call
an alpha plate and a charlie plate on
the top
there is a bravo and a delta that's
obscured right now by the 384 well plate
in each of the alpha bravo charlie and
delta sets
two positive controls and a negative
control are located in different
positions in the plates
uh and where they wind up on the 3d4
well plate is shown as shown in the
bottom panel so for example the positive
control 1
on the alpha plate is in well b1 that
winds up being
in well c1 on the 3d4 wall plate based
on how we interleave them
and similarly for the charlie plate
positive control 1 on a charlie plate
is in well let's see that would be a10
and it winds up on the three-day four
wall plate in well b19
so if an alpha charlie bravo or delta
plate were
rotated uh this pattern of controls of
positive control one negative
and positive control two would appear in
defined locations
so we have an algorithm that goes and
looks to see uh
whether that pattern appears where it it
should not
appear and confirms that it does appear
where it's expected to appear so that's
part of our
quality control process there are many
ways to solve this problem this is just
one that we found
operationally uh straightforward to
implement
okay now i want to go on to talk about
pathologies of the individual
assays and amplifications themselves and
some of this data was kindly provided by
thermo fisher
one of the updates to the instructions
for use
that came out fairly recently within the
last month and a half or so
was the importance of vortexing the 3d
four wall plate
as i mentioned the extracted rna has to
be mixed very well with
the real-time pcr master mix in
probe and primer mix the density excuse
me the viscosity of the master mix
is very high and so it's very important
to vortex this very thoroughly
if you do not do that what you see
in the very early cycles of the assay as
the temperature
fluctuates the temperature itself the
convection
is actually driving mixing and so you
see
some changes in the signal in the first
few cycles
as the assay is mixed thermally
had it been mixed um through vortexing
this background in the first few cycles
would be
flat so this is something that's fairly
easy to pick up on is now and is now
part of our standard curve review
um if you look at an amplification plot
again
you would see this substantial amount of
background in the first few cycles
as evidence that the plate was not well
mixed
so package insert now says not only
vortex this very carefully but also
check the curves of every run to ensure
that
it has in fact been well mixed
all right um other examples
of irregular curves that may occur for
example if there was an inhibitor or
some other
methodological problem went wrong um the
the upper
upper left graph shows a great
amplification curve you know clear
exponential amplification meaning a nice
linear region in a log plot
um in this case of all four targets so
things working quite nicely
the graph to the right of that that says
not true pcr amplification
you see a few amplification curves that
are shaped exactly as expected and you
see others that
that rise abruptly and then have a
sharp elbow and a long drift cycle
that is not true pcr amplification it
may have something to do with irregular
background in early cycles or may have
something to do with
another unusual reaction condition
bottom left not true pcr amplification
with high background you can see these
what we call lazy curves that are rising
slowly over time
um and to the to the left you see that
the background in the first few cycles
is nearly the same level
of the of the curves during
amplification
and then bottom right you see quite a
sporadic signal almost a sawtooth
pattern uh in some of these which again
may be related to an instrument issue an
electrical noise issue
or something related to the assay but
these are not real curves
and merit further investigation before
data like that would be
would be moved forward for release
okay um so that expands on some of the
pathologies now i want to get into
um looking at large sets of data that
we've generated over the last several
months so
uh with over a hundred thousand data
points um
you know it's always interesting to look
at the the three targets that are in the
assay there's the in gene the s gene and
the orf one a b
region of the uh sars cov2 genome
and so i've plotted here um
uh sort of a two dimensional density
plot of the ct values of these various
targets
and so this would indicate for example
if the
n-gene ct
is well i'll say it this way if the s
gene ct
is slightly higher than the n gene ct at
the same
sample then it would suggest that the n
gene
is slightly more sensitive at detecting
stars cov2
than the s gene so that's this little
kick up that you see at the very end but
overall
uh you know very near linear throughout
the the dynamic range of the assay
n versus orf1 again very similar s
versus rf1
again pretty similar you might infer
from this that uh
you know all in gene is the most
sensitive or f1ab
is the next most sensitive s is is
probably the least sensitive of the
three
um but still valuable across uh across
time
um you'll also notice uh something this
struck me when i was putting this data
together that there's a bit of
vital modality you'll see there's a bit
more concentration
down here in the low ct ranges you know
so these would be we would call this
high viral load although we
would hesitate to say that a nasal swab
is an accurate way to
to capture a viral load um but certainly
within the assay you know this is a lot
of virus
uh in the ct values between sort of 15
and 20.
and then there's another peak up here in
the around
30 cts and we'll expand on that in in
the next slide
so this was 100 000 data points taken
over
uh several months if i now look
over time um i'm showing you that same
data but by week of the year so week 23
was june 1st the week of june
1st the last panel on this graph week 34
was august 19th so as you'll recall
uh and certainly within the geographies
that we serve texas and
and the southwest um you know the
pandemic was
really uh creeping back up you know post
post-memorial day and uh uh
so we believe you know the data suggests
that there were
very many high viral loads uh in these
first few weeks of june going through
all of june
and then starting in sort of uh july
uh we had a lot of people testing if you
you
might remember from the popular media uh
there was an absolute
surge in demand for testing in a few
weeks in july
and so as that surge occurred
you see this bimodality emerge uh where
we still have some very high positives
but we also have some very weak
positives represented by the
the the peaks at higher ct values up
around 30.
and in fact that trend just continues
and so now the the
majority of the peak is actually at ct
values
higher than 30 as of the week of august
19th
um to expand on that story a little bit
more what we've seen
sort of from an epidemiological
perspective uh positivity rate
at least in the southeast um
really blossomed so this graph shows you
you know by
date positivity rate uh so i've i've
drawn lines at ten percent and twenty
percent
uh starting just after july fourth you
know we
we pretty consistently went over 20
positive
uh in the samples that we were testing
and then
as we expanded into august that
positivity rate dropped back below
uh 20 percent and in fact today it's
back down below 10
um but as that positivity rate
followed that course the ct values that
we see just the average ct values these
are box plots of ct values
tended to drift up um and this might
suggest that
for example either people who were
suspicious of disease and catching it
earlier were being tested
or people who perhaps had had the
disease and now we're in late stage and
wanting to confirm
no residual nucleic acid existed we're
coming back to be tested
unfortunately as a laboratory we don't
really get to understand
every patient's clinical trajectory so i
can't easily tease those apart but the
data certainly suggests
that there were a large number of people
being tested uh perhaps late
in uh in an infectious state or after
they had already had acute disease
um the other story here of course is
that uh while we're very pleased with
the tack path
uh turnaround time and capacity
it still is only a certain amount of
capacity so
the huge demand that erupted in
june you can see that's when the
positivity rate started to spike up
and our turnaround times uh you know we
try to maintain turnaround times well
under 48 hours because that's the most
useful
turnaround time for the test is as fast
as possible
but once you're completely uh you know
the testing demand far
outstrips the uh capacity of any
laboratory and this was
every laboratory in the country was
being outstripped at the time
uh the turnaround times by necessity
increased but since then you can see
they've been quite low and stable
all right uh the final sort of
interesting clinical picture here is to
look
at as i mentioned we do antibiotics as
well so in some cases i was able to find
patients who
we had tested with the tacpath assay and
later tested
with either the igt antibody or the
total antibody
and i haven't discriminated between the
two and i'm just asking the question you
know sort of does biology work
um so this is looking at
patients who had uh positive antibody
tests
that were more than two weeks after an
initial
uh nucleic acid test that was also
positive and we're just asking the
question what do the ct values look like
and you see the ct values are broadly
distributed there's
this sort of bi-modality to it i
wouldn't put a whole lot of faith in
that because
as i recall there's not a huge amount of
data in this
but it does indicate that uh you know
people who were acutely infected at one
point with perhaps a very high ct
did develop an antibody response if i
now change the question slightly and say
show me patients who had a positive
nucleic acid test
and a later antibody result but it was
less than two weeks after so perhaps
they did not
develop fully uh an immune response
in uh between the two tests you see that
their
ct values are consistently only very
high and this suggests to us
that uh these are patients who were
tested by nucleic acid very early
uh in their infection right when they
were
had very low viral load and the time
between
the detection here and the antibody test
was too short their immune system had
not actually developed detectable levels
of antibody
so the the story here is that the you
know covid
does follow traditional infectious
disease routes and we see the
both nucleic acid antibody responses
that you would expect
all right so that's uh that's it i would
be happy to take any questions and thank
you again for the opportunity